is it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that on TV on radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
TV Nick curios is the Undisputed bad boy
of tennis racking up a world record half
a million p in fines she's drunk out of
her m in the first row speaking to me in
the middle of the day he's more famous
for his volleys of abuse than his actual
volleys thinking aim as Spectators looks
like she's about 700 drinks bro
Superstars and me I've told curios to
grow up if you're watching Mr curious I
think you do watch show just grow up you
big baby he's told me to eat a tonight
in the most unlikely exclusive of the
Year I'll find out if you regret some of
those sentiments I hated myself I hated
waking up and being Nick curios whether
there's a softer side to the tennis hard
man the cuos family has definitely dealt
with their fair share of racism um in
Australia will I break his nerve or will
nasty Nick finally win that elusive
Grand
[Music]
Slam
from the news building in London this is
Pier Morgan
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to PE Morgan uncensored tonight
an exclusive interview with a sporting
Superstar and someone I genuinely never
thought would ever agree to be
interviewed by
me well I'm joined Now by Nick curios
the interview nobody on planet Earth
thought would ever happen is now about
to happen so Nick how are you good peers
how are are you how's everything going
well I thought it might be useful for
viewers who are not familiar with our
beef I believe is the vernacular term
these days to go over the beef over the
last few years and explain how we
reached this place um it goes back to
2016 you played Andy Murray sounds good
uh you threw a legendary strop even by
your standards and I tweeted the
following never seen an Australian Suk
like curios normally ferocious proud
competitors embarrassing
uh I then added you should put your toys
back in the pram to which you responded
E A now I didn't know what EAD meant
until one of my sons informed me it
meant eat a
dick so perhaps we could start with that
one nick uh um it was a very you know it
was a very to the point comment uh do
you have any regrets about your response
or did you think it was fair enough um
yeah I think it was I think it was
warranted definitely um I actually sent
that from a from a restaurant I had a
couple beers and I saw your comment on
Twitter and I was just like I'm in no
mood to deal with anything like this at
the moment and I just sent it so yeah I
mean look Andy Murray he's an absolute
legend of the sport and yeah I got I got
given a lesson that day and yeah it was
not a good showing for me but I guess a
couple years later made the final of
Wimbledon so you would have enjoyed
seeing that right P well funny enough
you weren't the only person to to come
back at me with a comment like that on
Twitter around that period Rihanna uh I
told her to grow her hair after she
revealed some short bob when she
appeared on stage in London and she
replied grow a dick so there was a
running theme to uh to Global figures uh
basically calling me a dick in various
ways I mean you can't blame her for
calling you one sometimes you are a bit
of a a bit of a dick I guess well I got
to say coming from you pot
Kettle now look I've been called a lot
worse than
that well let's move to the second phase
of the of the beef uh in an interview
with the New York Times after this
exchange which got a bit of traction
online as we know uh you confessed you
confessed you never watched tennis Y and
you responded no chance Jesus I'd rather
watch Pier
Morgan yeah I mean that's that's
actually a compliment you should take
that as a compliment because I'd
actually probably rather watch one of
your segments on TV than a tennis match
so that's actually I don't know why you
would take that as beef that's a
compliment like you're you're
entertaining so and we all know that
that's why people watch me from time to
time it's not also about the quality
it's just about you know how much fun am
I going to have in 30 minutes so I'd
rather watch you for sure definitely
that's a compliment look I'm we could be
friends I think you you're you're I
think we're very alike you know what we
probably more alike than I would care to
admit and I suspect we will be friends
after this um things move forward then
to Wimbledon last year obviously you're
on a tear you're playing fantastically
you are a genius tennis player I'm going
to put that on the table now I love
watching you play however that you you
can let yourself down Nick let's just
put it politely uh and on one occasion
during the tournament you let yourself
down and you were throwing stuff around
and abusing everyone and I labeled you
on this show the douche of the day let's
take a look at the clip one of my least
favorite people Nick curios you know
what bro you're my douche of the day
every day if you're watching Mr C I
think you do watch the show just grow up
you big
baby any
thoughts yeah but okay look I'm not
going to sit here and say that I'm on my
best behavior all the time but these
clips that you show are only like 10 to
15 seconds worth of what the tennis
match is there's four or three to four
hours where I'm incredibly well behaved
I'm like competing and I'm playing
worldclass tennis then you choose to
show 10 seconds of a 4H hour match I
mean I can't control that but I do
understand like sometimes yeah I I could
be a douche on the tennis court but
that's just what it is I mean let's be
clear it I do hours and hours a week of
of live television uh I think to a
pretty high standard but if I was to
spend 10 seconds every week throwing
throwing things at the cameraman and uh
swearing and shouting and throwing my
toys out the pr people would focus on
that Nick probably not the rest of my
programming okay but again you're you
again you are exaggerating it's not
every week it's not every week there
goes there's like months and months
where nothing happens and then the
minute something happens again you just
say that oh he here he is doing it again
where it could be like a six month
Hiatus of me not doing anything so I
mean look there's only so much control I
can have well the main reason you and
you're also acting as if I'm the only
tennis player who Who does these things
no no you're not you're not some of the
legends of the sport of broken rackets
oh yes oh well no no you're the modern
day John mro I'm going to come to that
because I know that you've got you've
developed a bit of a rapport with
macenroe let's go back to Wimbledon
again uh in the same tournament I then
had a strange feeling it was a strange
feeling came over me because there was
this furor about you wearing your
Jordans um and you kept insisting on
doing it and you had tication with a
journalist and I suddenly found myself
tweeting the following I said he's such
an unrelenting uncompromising douchebag
that to my horror I'm actually beginning
to warm to Nick curios wh why to your
horror why why why are you afraid of
liking me I'm just myself I'm not going
to conform to like look Wimbledon for me
is the Pinnacle of tennis if not one of
the biggest sports sporting um you know
events we have in the world so I have
utmost respect for everything that it
represents and every time I'm there I
you know I have Goosebumps I I
understand the this the relevance of the
event and you know I think I just put my
touch on it I'm not trying to change
wimon but Nick curios is trying to bring
his touch towards wimon with you know a
slight red hat or some red Jordans
majority of is white like I'm wearing
white I'm going out there playing in
front of millions of fans you know
giving the you know England uh some some
good tennis so I don't understand why I
got so much hate for that and I think
that's a picture that I'll remember for
the rest of my life you know that's when
Nick Kiros is all said and done in his
tennis career making the wimon final
putting on that red hat meeting the
queen and you know doing that is is is
pretty cool I think so I can understand
why you're warming up to me well I was
definitely warming up to you and then we
met a incredible Common Ground we
discovered we feel exactly the same way
about somebody else in the World of
Sport and it was Megan rapino the uh
female soccer player as they call it in
America and it came after this clip
where she uh basically treated a young
boy trying to get an autograph I thought
was appalling dismissiveness of we got
the
clip well I gave my my pretty strong
views about this on Twitter uh and you
actually
replied ha
haa one thing me and PE agree on so we
finally bonded over Megan rapino being a
spoiled petulent brat yeah look again
I'm not going to come on here and and
you know criticize athletes I know that
she's got you know millions of fans
worldwide and in this moment in time she
may have been dealing with things and
you may be very dismissive I'm not going
to sit here and say I've been amazing to
every fan that I've ever signed um you
know tennis ball for or anything for but
you know every time you know it's it's a
young kind of kid I do my best to try
and look involved because I used to be
that person when I was um young you know
I had my idols and when they signed
tennis balls for me I was always super
super excited so I know the relevance
and and the importance of being present
in those moments and you know someone
like me that I don't know if you know
because you dislike me so much I
actually try and give back a lot to the
community and and spend um time with
kids and and you know actually met a
make a wish kid you know a couple weeks
ago and I enjoyed that type of stuff so
um yeah I mean I don't really like the
dismissiveness but
you know I haven't been perfect either
well let me be let me just put this on
the table uh I've actually grown to
really like you and that may be the
worst thing you hear from me all day but
I I actually had because I watched the
the Netflix uh thing uh found out a lot
more about you about your life about
your upbringing what you'd come through
um and the honesty I felt that you
brought to what you'd gone through and
the
self-awareness that you had I felt look
I I wouldn't use a phrase as patronizing
as it felt like you'd grown up but it
definitely felt like you'd evolved as a
human being and we're able to look back
on that period when we first locked
horns and recognized that that was not a
path to any Glory that was just going to
be completely self-defeating would that
be would that be fair yeah I think we
all we all grow up at our own um at our
own pace but yeah I definitely look to
look where I was in 2016 where you and I
had the run in and look a bit of credit
would have been nice from you I mean it
fourth round of Winwood and against one
of the greatest of all time I thought
that in itself was a pretty good
achievement but um yeah look I've grown
up um immensely um I look back at you
know those Twitter beefs that I've had
I've had one with you I've had one with
Drake and I just look back and I'm just
saying like these is just so so silly
and when I've met all these people that
I've had beef with we actually get along
extremely well I mean I could imagine
that you and I could go for a beer and
for a drink and we'd have a great time
with all the stories and experiences
that we've both had but yeah that I
guess that Netflix um series was really
good for me personally because it gave a
bit of background into you know people
think that I've been entitled and got
given everything off a plate but you
know when I was young my family didn't
have much you know I had to kind of work
for everything that was thrown my way
and yeah I went through my own struggles
and it was common struggles that most
people do go through so that's why I'm
very relatable so I think that's why it
was very important it's an interesting
part of the Netflix thing were you the
shows about some of the critics you've
had and I I pop up let's take a look at
that you having a bit of a interaction
if you like the line judges and at one
point I think you said you're in your
'90s you can't see the ball I hit a ball
in right the old man called it out it
was in so so arguably if the guy was 40
he may not have called that out do you
have any sympathy with how sometimes
they're treated by players for
example they're not getting abused on
social media like I have to deal with my
girlfriend deals with hate messages my
family deals with hate messages I deal
with hate
messages okay thank you very much wor
thanks thank you very much
the man's out of control can you put up
any defense for this antipa monster
there's plenty of Australians who think
he's an absolute
tool I got to say it's it's slightly
awkward looking at some of the stuff I
said about you with you sitting there
watching me as I do it but um but in a
way you kind of brought that treatment
on yourself you know I would argue I
think you felt like it was part of your
brand you're an un uncompromising Brash
character right and you probably
factored in well this is going to make
me more interesting right not not not on
that particular day first of all Aon
Mullen that person the Australian uh
reporter I have no idea who that person
is so her opinion to me doesn't matter
and I'm I'm I'm happy she had a five
minutes of fame but um also yeah that
day like I've just played a 4 and 1/
half hour match and I brought my food
into the press conference because I'm
not sure I'm not sure if you've been an
a leate athlete before but when you
finish a match at four for 4 hours you
need to fuel your body because it's a
like a very crucial part of your
recovery so I thought I'd bring my sushi
in to the press conference room because
I had media to do and I didn't want to
make people wait because people have
bookings for the media room so there's a
lot of things that happen behind the
scenes that I got criticized for and you
know many other tennis players have
brought beers into the press conference
room eating in the press conference room
and they don't get absolutely battered
in the media for it I just brought some
sushi and thought I'd kill two birds
with one stone get my media done look
after my nutrition be professional but
obviously that got taken out for a spin
and it was like oh he's eating in a
press conference room he's he's Judas um
but you know that was that was hard but
I mean why would we I I just don't
understand it's Wimbledon it's one of
the biggest sporting events in the world
with millions of dollars on the line why
would we let line line calls be given to
chance why would we not have electric
line calling or at least give the
players the best chance to compete in a
fair environment so I'm just very black
and white I I'm not trying to act I just
strongly believe that there should be
electronic line calling because then it
doesn't leave hundreds and thousands of
dollars on the line to maybe a chance or
a bad day or or someone or something
like that and sorry that I was just
looking after my nutrition with with
five bits of sushi my goodness
jeez you know what I had to eat I'll
give you the I'll give you the first
point I agree with you about the line
calling it is ridiculous if you have
some old crusty at wimon who can barely
see straight ruling something out when
it's in or the other way around thank
you I'm not going to give you Sushi
because Roger federa would never do that
because he's too classy and he'd have
too much respect for the journalist so
that you're you're not going to get pass
on that but I'm not Roger feda you can't
expect everyone to be Roger federa you
can't you can't do that that's unfair
that's very unfair that means 99% of the
tennis tour are not up to Roger federis
standard that that's sport that's
personality like you do know what I mean
he also has nine people in his team to
make sure that he has food ready I only
had three I had my girlfriend I had my
best friend my agent and my physio so we
don't I don't have the luxury of having
13 people to tie my shoelaces like Roger
federa or you know make sure I have a
white vest to walk on the court with I
have to do these things mostly on my own
so that's where bit of understanding
like to compare Nikos to Roger Federer
is ridiculous well hang on I'm not
comparing you to him as a player or
anything to do with his Entourage or
anything I'm just saying he'd never eat
sushi at a press conference which is
something you don't need to be told what
to do do you but but what what's what's
wrong with that I'm I'm looking after my
nutrition and it's it's a very common
thing that tennis players do in in every
tournament it's not it's not abnormal
for a player to eat or snack on
something because I just came off the
court I didn't have any time to do
recovery they they told me that was my
press conference time so I had to eat I
had to eat what how would you feel what
do you want me to do how would you feel
if while we're talking right now in an
interview that's going to be beamed
around the world I just start munching
on
sushi but you but you didn't play you
didn't play at wimon for 4 hours you
have no idea what I've been you had
ample time to prepare to get breakfast
tennis yeah but ten tennis tennis is one
of the only sports in the world where
you don't know how long the will go for
and it's it could be an hour and a half
it could be 4 hours so plans change you
have to be very adapt you have to be
able to adapt that's why Novak's for me
the greatest athlete because there's not
like it's like a football match where
you play a certain 90 minutes or you
know it's a NBA game where you have 48
minutes of it's like there's so many
things and intangibles that can happen
like I had to eat it was not obviously
if I my match went for an hour and a
half I would have said oh yeah know I'll
eat later but I had to eat at that time
okay look I'm not going to sit here and
and like if I was talking to rapael
Nadal or Novak joov i''d be like yeah no
100% but here's Morgan it's like it's a
problem well I tell you what it's a
problem for me is your inference earlier
that I don't understand the mentality of
an elite tennis player I'd like to play
you a clip of when I took on Serena
Williams in New
York oh God here we go let's have a look
at
this so
bad oh come
[Applause]
on that was nice oh you're carrying on
like Nick curios it's like you know what
I'm proud of you it was I'm proud of you
it wasn't wimbl but you know I didn't
want to play that clip but you forced me
into it with your taunting about me not
being Elite level tennis player that is
me beating the greatest female player in
history uh I'm not claiming any credit
obviously I'm a man I'm more powerful
I'm faster um more skillful uh but a win
a win yeah you looked good your
Technique was a lot better than I
thought but you looked in a bit better
shape back then Pier so how about when I
get healthy we uh we take it to the
courts and and we sort it out once and
for all well you know what I'll do that
and uh and actually I do need a bit more
sushi in my diet that's
true got to lay off the
points
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we're
on your smart speaker as well criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn do you know what I love
about support today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swearing off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about1 140 million £140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for AIT if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald MC Mouse man
MC mous man MC man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
Phill sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do I'm going
you're going to Res yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a r you can't can
you I've asked you two questions should
a mass stay in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
[Music]
I want to play you a more serious clip
mate uh because it's good fun joshing
with you and you obviously got a good
sense of hum but I want to play another
clip from the the Netflix uh Series this
is where you talk about when you went
off the
rails I hated the kind of person I
was I was drinking
abusing
drugs lost my relation to my family
pushed all my close friends
away you could tell I was hurting like
my whole arm was covered in scars and
that's why I actually got my arm sleeve
to cover it
all 21 team was is
tough Nick was when yeah Nick
was I've just never seen someone go
through and that's why sometimes oh my
God I get so upset when someone
says like bad things about him because
they don't
know I was genuinely contemplating if I
wanted to commit
suicide I found that really shocking
Nick and I read another interview you
gave a print interview and you talked
about feeling incredibly lonely uh very
disconnected from your family you were
drinking heavily sometimes 20 30 drinks
a night before big matches taking drugs
partying till dawn on one occasion at
wimon in 2018 your manager couldn't get
hold of you and used a phone app to
track you and found you were 26 miles
away passed out in a random stranger's
house and you would spend days lying in
the dark uh cutting and burning yourself
um and I I got to say I found that
incredibly shocking but also incredibly
courageous of you to put all this out
there for the public public to to learn
yeah um I think I was at the point of my
career last year when I came out about
it and I was ready to open up I think I
think last year I was actually ready to
just put my story out there and you know
when I watch those clips that you just
played they're really emotional but at
the same time inside I feel a lot better
than I I used to feel about that and you
know I feel like the I've helped so many
people like after I opened up about it
and put on social media and obviously
the Netflix documentary highlighted a
lot more of it um I've almost been a
beacon for people who are struggling and
you know when they feel like they're
overwhelmed and they're going towards
you know drinking and drugs and stuff
they they open up and they feel like
unrelatable because if someone like me
can first of all make it to the tennis
tour and then deal with all that as well
as playing like those those nights that
I was having were before playing people
like Rafael Nadal um you know playing
quality players on the ATB tour and and
still being successful I guess where I
was in the darkest period of my life so
if I'm able to pull myself out of it um
that's one of being the most powerful
thing in my career is people come to me
with genuine issues and they send me
photos in my Instagram DMS of them you
know self Haring and and genuinely
wanting to commit suicide and I have
conversations with these people
sometimes you know I've had phone calls
with these people and you know that's
making a real difference for my career
and I'm just really proud that I'm you
know I watch those clips and I'm not
really emotional about it I start
smiling because cuz I know now the
importance of family and how much those
loved ones actually just wanted to care
for me and protect me through all the
criticism and you know when I couldn't
deal with it but now you know it's it's
night and day different so what was the
absolute Rock Bottom moment for you when
you look back at that period oh there
was there was I don't think there was
one select um moment I think it was just
all a year and a half to two years of
just
complete just harm I think it was it it
was was pretty dark to be honest um you
know I W I won tornament you know on the
professional tour drinking every night
self Haring I used to you know was
burning things on my arm cutting myself
for fun and you know I had people around
me saying this is not normal behavior
and I did have people around me that
were caring but I just it was almost the
more I kept doing it it became an
addiction of of pain and and you know I
just didn't like I I hated myself I
hated waking up and being Nic curios I
hated going to places and tournaments
and no one actually wanted to talk to me
at face value they just wanted me to be
the the Entertainer or the crazy nuc
curios so I didn't feel like who I
actually was was of any worth and it
just got out of control but then you
know I somehow dug myself out of the
hole so nothing you say on Twitter can
can phas me pi nothing that is very
obvious actually um what also came clear
was that Andy Murray uh saw these marks
on your arms and he reached out to you
didn't he uh how important was that yeah
Andy Andy was always a big supporter of
of me as soon as I came on the tour he I
don't know he kind of
saw a work in progress I I think and and
he always try and took me under his wing
and then he realized later in my career
that I was I don't think I was coachable
or could you know I was on my own path
but he was always someone that was
looking out for me and one of the best
for me so yeah he saw it and he said
what's that on your arm and it was
pretty bad at that stage when you know
these These are people in the locker
room so I'd be in the locker room and
they people would be able to see myself
harm so I could only imagine what people
would think when they were actually
versing me on the tennis court they're
like wow this guy is mentally in a in in
a storm at the moment and he's still
trying to play and um it would have been
alarming for for some of these players
to seen and Andy was saying look you
should obviously was trying to give me
advice on it but I was just so stuck in
my ways at that time that I didn't
listen and obviously I'm very thankful
if he ever watches this I'm sure curios
and P Morgan I'm sure he's going to tune
in at some stage um so yeah I thank I
thank him a lot was there one person who
said something to you which managed to
start the beginning of the future for
you when you look back yeah you just
touched on it um everyone that was you
know in my circle or my loved ones
always told me the right thing to do but
I guess it was just conversations that I
had with myself um it was you know at
the end of the day you can have everyone
around you telling you which direction
to go but if you don't think that's the
right way then you're not going to get
out of it and I I just had a
conversation with Myself and I I was
like look we got to got to do something
about it so I I I just tried little bit
by little just to get some good habits
make some right choices um and yeah look
last year
was the best year of arguably the best
year of my career nearly won a grand
slam um had the third best season on the
planet um and I just from where I was to
that it was so emotional for me
personally cuz I just didn't think it
was possible I thought my time had gone
where I'd have success off the court and
on the court you know I had a great part
part had a great friendship group and
had amazing success in it I I'd never
thought it was possible to be this happy
but I think that it's just more I think
it was me just day by day making the
right choices I actually wanted you to
win that final thanks uh I mean I'm
surprised you've ever want me to win a
tennis match I think you'd rather me
just lose all the time well
instinctively I don't like Australians
winning anything particularly Cricket uh
but no I did I felt like you you just
electrified the tournament and you know
I I I thought that this is a guy who's
complicated but I used to like watching
mackenro I feel like over time people
have kind of been more comfortable with
me just being nios it's like okay we we
know that we're if we buy tickets in
nios we don't know what we're going to
get we could get explosive tennis we
could get entertaining T we could get
something absolutely off planet Earth
that you've never seen before he might
do something crazy and I think that's
part of the the show I think Sport and
entertainment is one and I think that's
why it's important you have to have
different personalities in sport
otherwise it's just it will get a bit
stale and boring and I think you look at
that c pass match with me and wimon it
was it was insane like it was incredible
it was one of the best matches I've ever
been a part of because of the crowd was
involved the people were involved they
made a Netflix do documentary of it um
so I mean look I've had I've definitely
had a lot of fun um playing my style of
tennis but look if you're going to
compare me to the greats of tennis then
you've you've set me up for failure you
said I don't mind being the a villain
I've definitely experienced stadiums
where not one person's been going for me
it's a great feeling you find some
really dark energy when the whole
stadium doesn't want you to win those
are some of the best moments the only
thing I've had like that in my life is
when I was a judge on America's Got
Talent and I was playing the bag you
know the tough meany judge and I know
that feeling to a degree in the sense of
when they're all booing me I used to
love it and so I I do get that dark
energy part I've had it in a very
different way but I get it and I used to
get off on it right I mean and you
clearly do I've seen you yeah you feel
you feel like you feel like the the bad
guy in in a movie you feel like the main
villain and I love it you know I used to
love going out not So Much Anymore when
when I go out to stadiums around the
world now it's like people are cheering
people are going crazy people wanting to
see the curios I guess the show and and
they're very supportive where back in
the day when I used to show up to places
it was like even for practice even when
I entered the site I needed extra
security guards compared to the other
players because of the hate people just
used to hate seeing my presence around
the courts and they would boo my
practices they would throw in Shanghai
one year people were throwing glass
bottles on the court it was just it was
it was a riot and something just drove
me to it was just like addictive every
time I went out on the court I knew that
I could spoil someone's day I knew that
I could just upset someone be be the bad
guy in The Fairy Tale so it was it was a
good feeling but um I think being loved
a little bit better being appreciated
and and being supported is definitely I
think healthier but yeah the the villain
was good for a little
bit we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online onun your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all soon Act
sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon had the other
the police appr Pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an Al in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a FSE or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £ 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news is
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan should have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
manc he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are there a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV it's the
only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that this is talk
[Music]
TV the um I mean you talked about ma
androe being defaulted and you were very
proud of the fact you've never got that
far you are the most fined player in the
history of tennis uh £ 452,000
of fines are you proud of that record it
goes to charity so on the flip side I
could be the most generous ATP player
ever you said that with a completely
straight face yeah look I'm not I'm not
look sometimes when I watch my
highlights back and I realized look I
probably shouldn't have done that look
there's some some regret in some of my
actions obviously like I'm not going to
sit here and say no that was always
warranted no sometimes I do cross the
line but competitors out there know that
and I think if you look at other sports
you know trash talking is normal you
know these behaviors aren't as I guess
repulsive but because it's tennis it's
it's under a microscope it's very
traditional and I understand that you um
I know you don't well you s that you
don't want to you can't comment about
the clip I'm about to show you from
Wimbledon last year but it was a famous
clip and really I just want to play it
to see what your facial re like let's
take a
look okay but why is she still here
she's drunk out of in the first row
speaking to me in the middle of the game
what's acceptable nothing is acceptable
okay so kick her out I don't know which
one is it I know exactly which one it is
so tell me the one dress with the one
that looks like she's had about 700
drinks
from I got to say I did laugh yeah
that's just it was he of the moment and
that's not the only time that something
like that happen you know you you're
playing in the biggest tournaments in
the world Wimbledon Australian Open
French Open US Open and at these crucial
moments I think people sometimes
Spectators they don't understand that it
can just be a fall in concentration for
20 seconds and then that can swing the
entire tennis match and especially
against someone like Novak I needed you
know the Stars to align that day but
yeah look hit of the moment quick chat
you you and I both know In the Heat of
the Moment we do come up with some of
our best stuff so um
yeah look it's true I can't control
sometimes I would like the crowd to
understand the the severity of just one
point in a tennis match one point in
tennis match can swing for the next 20
minutes so yeah it's it's it's it's
tough at at the uh at the start of your
career when you were about 20 and things
were really going off the rails Shane
War the late great Australian cricketer
who was a good friend of mine he he
wrote an open letter to you this is
after that defeat to Andy Murray after I
did my my tweet to you actually and he
said dear Nick curios I was to read read
what he wrote D ni curios we all realize
you're only 20 have a lot to learn buddy
please don't waste your talent everyone
in the world especially us Australians
want to respect you remember respect is
way more important than being liked you
need to respect the game of tennis and
yourself we all make mistakes but it's
how we learn from them and the way we
conduct ourselves when we lose that
shows true character you're testing our
patients mate show us What You're Made
Of and how hungry you are to be the best
in the world it's time to step up and
start winning no excuses no shame in
losing but show us you'll never give up
you'll give everything to be the best
you can be respect is earn not given I
believe in you I know you can do it but
now's the time my friend my first
question is did you did you see that
open L of a time uh yeah I saw it um and
didn't read it um but yeah uh look I
feel like I've been the closest
Australian player
in the last decade to win a grand slam I
was I made the final um I've had a
pretty successful career I feel like
I've won a lot more than I've lost um
able to provide for my family friends um
and yeah respected by millions around
the world obviously um and yeah I'm just
I've done it my way so look at the at at
at the end of the day I know that these
other Australian athletes um you know
just wanted to see me succeed and I've
only ever supported most of them them as
well and I've only wanted the best for
them I've never never going to be the
first one to go out on social media and
put someone down if someone does that to
me I'll respond but um yeah look I mean
I look back at that letter and I look
back of how far I've come and I'd say he
would be proud for sure I think he
absolutely would and there's a lot about
your personality which is very warny
like you know it wasn't like he was any
by his own admission he was no angel um
this was a guy that went through a lot
of stuff himself I think he genuinely
was trying to give you ad from someone
who'd been there in the cold face of The
Cauldron of international sport
recognized you were young saw some
traits perhaps of his own Y and was
genuinely trying to help it did you ever
meet Shane after that no I never I never
was able to meet Shane I guess his
schedule would have been excuse me um
his schedule would have been crazy and
obviously with my travel I think that
would have been one person that would
have probably we would have got along
really really well yeah um but yeah look
um I I I I haven't met too many of these
Australian athletes just cuz the the
schedules are so different and we just
have a lot going on your early story uh
Nick is really fascinating because you
were the last of three children uh born
to George your father and nil your
mother um your dad immigrated to
Australia uh from Greece age seven and
was a a decorator your mom was born in
Malia as part of the Royal Family
actually and moved to Australia with her
mother when she was 12 and became a s
engineer it's an unusual pathway uh for
for someone like you to have come from
this this background and this journey
your parents went on how much is their I
I guess resilience they would have had
to have had to have gone through all
this when they were young how much of
that streak is in you from that do you
think huge I mean that's where most of
my motivation comes from you know my dad
is nearly getting on the latest ages of
60 and continues to work every day you
know his mindset um you know came with
nothing and everything that he's built I
guess he he sees me kind of carrying the
work and doing you know these interviews
or you know being an entrepreneur in a
couple things and obviously playing the
tennis I think he's super proud because
he sees you know some of his work ethic
in in me and I try and that's really
part of my motivation and you know my
mom obviously has dealt with so many
different health issues over the last
decade and especially over the last two
years you know so every day with her is
a blessing and I understand that and
it's it's it's been hard playing
majority of my career with my mom having
severe health problems it's been tough
but she's one of the strongest women I
know and um yeah those I I have honestly
everyone that comes to my house they
understand how amazing my parents are
they they they look after everyone they
feed everyone they make sure they try
and connect with everyone make everyone
feel special and yeah I mean look there
they're the best I I have no complaints
they with the I look back at some of the
the dinners that we had you know we had
$20 for three for three children at
dinners and and and I didn't know any
different I I I was growing up thinking
I had the best life so um she my mom was
awesome my dad's awesome so that's yeah
yeah in in May this year your mother was
held up at gunpoint by a masked man at
the family's home in in CRA you gave
Chase and actually injured your foot
resulting in missing the the French Open
that's a scary thing to happen
particularly with your mother having
already going through health issues yeah
just just tough you know thinking about
that moment it's still very raw it was
actually quite recent
um just yeah that's that's something
that I never thought would that my
career would bring would be people you
know coming to my doorstep where my my
family have lived for 30 plus years and
you know you hold a gun to my to my mom
and ask for a car it's like to to to
come steal a car
it's it's you could take the car but the
trauma that you've left on on my mom and
our family is is I think you can't heal
ever from something like that um so yeah
look it my career has brought me many
beautiful things in the platform I have
to help people's amazing but these are
things that just I have to deal with
that majority of humans don't deal with
and it's been really hard for the family
to get over that um yeah it was just a
it was
a horrific morning to be honest I just
remember my mom screaming and I I rushed
to the front door cut my foot on
something and it was just gashing out
blood and it was just it was a disaster
so yeah I mean look we're but we're a
strong contingent we're going to get
through it and my mom's doing you know
she's seeing people to help her um
mental state o over it still and you
know she'll be she'll be fine did you
what happened to the person that did
this um I think he's you know legally
going to get dealt with and and we'll
see your mother um recently also said
that it she can't watch you play anymore
that it just makes are too anxious and
she stopped watching it how did you feel
about that uh yeah well she's got a
pacemaker now as well so I don't think
she could come to any my matches um
especially Australian Open or Wimbledon
with the ups and downs and the the
craziness that happens I mean it it's
just too risky so um she watches from
home so my whole team usually comes
watch me play and if I'm in Australia
everyone will come watch live and she'll
just stay back at the accommodation or
wherever we're staying and just watch it
on TV and and support me from there and
I know that she's watching me all the
time um I've stressed that woman out so
much and I'm sorry um I'll say that on
probably one of the biggest shows ever
but she she's really proud of my work
and how much that I've grown but yeah I
I just wish that maybe she can watch me
you know one last time if I you know
once I come back from injury and I'm
playing at this TR open I would love for
her to come just one more match um that
would be a dream you know to to watch
her cuz she was the one from from day
dot that was always there from under
under eights to 10 to to now so it would
be really really really special if she
can she can tough it out for for a
couple years more she uh did a a piece
with she talked about her own upbringing
when she first came from Malaysia to
Australia age 12 said it was quite
traumatic she said I can remember
sitting on a bench wishing that someone
would ask me to play those memories are
very painful to be isolated to be called
whatever names people call someone with
dark
skin um so that was racism she was
experiencing yeah we've the curios
family has definitely dealt with their
fair share of racism um in Australia
but look it's it's just such a silly
topic for me I I don't like speaking
about it but yeah it's it's been tough
um for us you know some of the legends
of our sport have have told told my me
and my family to go back to where we
came from and you know we've we've I was
born in Australia growing up there and
represented the country for for 27 years
with anything I've done so it's
definitely been something um that we've
had to deal with but it just makes you
stronger I've got incredibly thick skin
and it's all it's all a process and and
one day I hope that this Topic's just
not not mentioned anymore yeah when you
when you said that it's a silly thing
for you do you mean that it's just
something you have to constantly get
asked about deal with and you'd rather
that you could just be judged on the
content literally of your character and
your play than anything to do with your
skin color or background yeah definitely
I just feel like you know you look at my
friendship group I have you know I have
all different of friends from everywhere
and we just get along so well and I
think it's just such a silly topic you
know we're all human beings at the end
of the day we can all when we work
together we all do some incredible
things together um and yeah you know
whether you're white or black doesn't
matter to me so I'm uh yeah it's just a
very silly
topic we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about for today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the Tor love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palace that
is just not right you swearing off in
the police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pant there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pound so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we are
you going to be trusting sources like
meta and Google where is our unbiased
news going to come from Kell in winter
is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a livit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about 3 years hundreds and hundreds
of mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house for the
Bice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your IDE this
has been a party political broadcast on
behalf of the reform UK party hi
kids think all they have to do is take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok problem solve this is really
unfair what what what's unfair if it's
on camera we're not doing interviews yes
I'm going to do you're going to Res yes
cuz I cannot continue my work when I say
I am God I'm not joking did you feel
Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational
I've asked you two questions should a
mass stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that this is talk
[Music]
TV
you um your old Agent verse spoty wrote
down in his notepad at the time chubby
mouthy but unbelievable hand skills uh
you're definitely not chubby anymore um
and you've got unbelievable hand skills
still and you're still pretty mouthy so
he was two out of three survived but uh
it's quite amazing your your physical
transformation when you look at that
picture of yourself uh can can you
believe that guy has become one of the
great athletes of his country I mean
I'll take that as you call me
good-looking thanks P um Compliments are
hard to come by from you but yeah look I
look at these photos of when I was young
and yeah the the there's a fair glow up
that's for sure but um yeah look I
didn't think I think that's just hope
you look at those pictures when I was
young and any kid that has dreams and
and things they want to achieve just
that's that's your inspiration right
there for sure like I was overweight
most of my most of my life um so if I'm
able to pull it together and and you
know just keep chipping away it doesn't
happen overnight chipping away chipping
away you can get Piers Morgan to call
you good-looking on on on TV I think I
actually said you you'd lost wa I didn't
go as far I see you're goodl
looking don't know we'll Replay that
we'll save that clip I I'm I'm
definitely posting that tell me about
your love life because you're very happy
uh with Co haty you met online
2021 and within months you took a bold
move Nick curios you tattooed her name
on your thigh that is a perilous thing
to do early in a relationship yeah it is
um yeah me and Co met uh almost we've
almost been together for two years
December 31st is our anniversary um so
yeah life with her has been amazing um I
feel like you know you you love someone
when you you know you've been given a
bit of adversity we you know we did the
we traveled the world together with
Airport we had delays you know things
that I've come from the baggage that
I've brought into the relationship she's
she's dealt with it amazing um and we
just get a long well everything's easy
with her um and back to the tattoo I was
actually in a tattoo parlor and I was
getting something covered up and then
she was like I was like do you want me
to get you tattooed it was just like I
just threw it out there and then she was
like no no you don't have to and then
secretly I knew that that was me
shooting myself in the foot I was like
oh no I have I have to do it I have to
do it now so she was like no you better
do it and then I have to get a little
one on my on my leg and yeah it's fine
you know she's definitely the one i' I'm
parled that drama in relationships it's
it's it's a special one uh when you said
you were covering something out that
wasn't the name of a previous girlfriend
was it maybe maybe so you've done your
research actually I was guessing but it
made sense oh yeah guessing I was I was
legitimately guessing there's nothing on
here that says you were take getting rid
of a previous girl's name but it makes
sense if you're impetuous and put
women's names on your thighs you're
going to have to get rid of some of them
right yeah I guess
so do you think you're going to get
married I know you want four kids she
wants two I know that much but you're
going to get married how do how do you
know how do you know this stuff you
secretly love Nick curios you're a
stalker you know why I know cuz I'm a
proper professional journalist at the
top of my game like you in tennis hey
that's true I I'll give you I'll give
you props I'll give you props you are
very professional
and yeah look one day definitely um you
know I'm 28 now and obviously want to
have a big family one day you know I
think I'm a very family orientated
person so as she she's got an amazing
family back home in in Sydney so yeah I
I would love to have a basketball
team like I would try like to have five
six maybe um but yeah I think she's just
set on two so we'll see I'll ask you a
question I asked Cristiano Ronaldo and
Zlatan Ibrahimovic because you're
obviously at that level um which is let
me give you a choice you can win
Wimbledon next year you can beat jovic
in an absolute
Thriller uh or you can have great sex
but you can't have both which one are
you going to
take this is a tough question it's not
really a tough question um I'm taking
option two really cuz look I made the
final already so I mean I'm not going to
lose option two what are you going to do
about your career a lot of rumors flying
around that you were going to give up
retire if you'd beaten jovic last year
but you're still young I mean jovic is
like eight years older than you are you
really going to throw the toweling
anytime soon I mean is are we not in an
era where Cristiano Ronaldo and these
guys they show you can go until 40 I
mean could you not be doing this in five
six years maybe long longer yeah I think
um you know soccer's got a little bit of
a different you know setting you know
you don't have to compete at the
absolute highest level in the eepl or
you know the Leo you you have all these
different leagues where you can get paid
amazing amounts and kind of not play it
maybe you know 60 70% if if that was an
option for tennis definitely I would
reassess my options you know at the
moment I'm dealing with some health
issues so just trying to get back
healthy I I definitely don't see myself
you know going anywhere in any in the
near future but you know I want to get
back on the tour and have one to two
more really really good years and I
think that's possible um and then after
if if there's some more leagues you know
that are offering some nice money then
yeah I'll definitely look on extending
my career but you know there there's a
lot of work in the tennis world that
needs to be done um and yeah look I'm a
day-by-day guy I don't like setting
goals or plans I just take every day and
see how my body's feeling and you know
when I have kids one day I want to be
able to you know run outside without
pain and and play with them and and
still be pretty youthful so um yeah look
plans can change Nick curios it's been
actually a great pleasure and I mean
that uh you you given a great interview
uh I've grown to know you a lot better
and I think understand you a lot better
and like I say I was cheering you on
last summer and I can't wait for you to
be back in action and I feel like we
should go to the dog and fox in wion
village where I used to go as a kid and
we should just have a few pints and you
know start take this Bromance to the
next stage oh you're twisting my arm I
don't know if I can I don't know if I
can take you up on a few beers who
knows Nick curios thank you very much
see you peers see you
later
we're here thanks for joining us you
with talk TV on TV on radio online run
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn do you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us toana under zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
if you're walking